derrière moi la une de france ou
football celle qui secoue depuis ce
matin le monde du football
l'hebdomadaire s'interroge sur les
conditions d'attribution au qatar de la
coupe du monde en 2022
le journal n'hésite pas à parler de cas
target
le vote sera entaché par des affaires de
corruption et de pressions de la part de
cet état du golfe
mathieu méranville nathalie berthier
capa c'était le 2 décembre 2010 le qatar
obtient le mondial 2022 satisfaction
dans le pays et stupéfaction dans le
monde du foot
mais selon france football le vote
aurait été entaché d'irrégularités voire
de corruption
à tel point que les journalistes de
l'hebdomadaire parle de réattribuer le
mondial à un autre pays il faut
comprendre que la fifa c'est une somme
de culture c'est une somme de
comportement et tout le monde n'a pas la
même conception de l'éthique et d'une
forme d'intégrité donc effectivement mai
pour un vote tous les arrangements sont
possibles et aujourd'hui on pose
clairement la question jusqu'où jusqu'où
est allé le qatar dans l'application de
ce système soupçons de corruption donc
deux membres de la fifa aurait touché
plus d'un million d'euros pour favoriser
le choix du qatar
le journal cite semelle du secrétaire
général de la fifa ils ont acheté le
mondial
deuxième élément ses propos d'un ancien
salarié de la fifa qui parle de culture
de la corruption pour s'assurer une
issue favorable
le pays n'aurait rien laisser au hasard
ambassadeur de marque zidane aurait reçu
11 millions d'euros pour promouvoir
cette candidature lobbying politique
également
le journal évoque une rencontre secrète
à l'elysée avec nicolas sarkozy le
prince du qatar et michel platini le
thème rachat du psg et création d'une
chaîne de sport avec des fonds en
réponse michel platini récuse toute
manoeuvre présence à creuser m'a jamais
demandé de voter pour le qatar il m'a
parlé du qatar mais m'a jamais demandé
de voter des dollars qu'il faut tourner
les têtes
à tel point que les canaris veulent soit
faire jouer les matches dans des stades
réfrigérée soit organisé l'épreuve au
mois de décembre plus propice ce serait
une première
[Musique]